the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
update video
as you all know i like to keep everyone
up to date with any and everything that
goes on during the off season at game of
thrones and all of their successor shows
whenever i find out new information i
make sure all of you find out as well
thankfully there has been some updates
on house of the dragon very recently
now for those of you that might not know
or just don't remember
house of the dragon will be set within
the song of ice and fire universe
roughly 300 years before the events of
game of thrones
centuries before the events of game of
thrones house targaryen
the only family of dragon lords to
survive the doom of valyria
began living on dragonstone it all
starts with the legendary aegon the
conqueror
creator of the iron throne and it goes
on to recount the generations of
targaryens who fought to hold that
iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly ripped their dynasty apart
george rr martin did say if we want to
learn more about this show then we
should grab some of his books which are
dangerous woman in rogues and then his
most recent book fire and blood
so it sounds like the main event of this
show could be the dance of the dragons
but i have also seen things that say it
could be about aegon and his sisters
taking over westeros
honestly either one of those options
would be fantastic but if they did an
american horror story style show
they could do both making each season of
the show a different story altogether
as you all know the dance of the dragons
was a civil war during the targaryen's
reign of the seven kingdoms
a war of succession between aegon ii and
his half-sister rhaenyra
over their father viserys the first
throne this war was fought from 129
ac to 131 ac and it saw the deaths of
both rival monarchs
and the crowning of rhaenyra's son aegon
iii
now if you have not read any other books
and you have only seen game of thrones
then you most likely won't know who many
of these characters are but that's okay
because you did not know who anyone was
when you started game of thrones either
although this show will be very
different from game of thrones it will
still have all of those same ingredients
that made the show so great for so long
i might actually start making videos on
the fire and blood book
just like i am with the books in a song
of ice and fire i should make a video on
each chapter of fire and blood that way
you have a good idea of what to expect
in house of the dragon
if you would like to see those videos
let me know down below they've actually
been developing house of the dragon for
about four years now since 2016.
this was actually the first idea george
rr martin brought to hbo when they began
talking about making a successor show
so you know this is something george rr
martin really wants to see brought to
life
assuming it's done right so far it does
sound like they are on the right track
miguel sapochnick will be one of the
showrunners and if you don't know who
miguel sapochnick is
he is the man responsible for directing
some of the greatest episodes in
television history
for game of thrones he directed the
battle of the bastards
hard home and the winds of winter just
to name a few
that makes me think they will open up
the bank for these episodes because
miguel is known for making episodes look
like high budget films
he really knows how to bring things to
life on a massive scale
if he is the director for the dance of
the dragons we should be in for an
amazing experience
george rr martin ryan condell and three
writing assistants have been creating
the story for house of the dragon
i really hope that george doesn't
abandon this show like he did game of
thrones
since he is so focused on riding the
winds of winter i do wonder how often
george will be able to help them write
this successor show
now the really good news is even though
everything is still on lockdown right
now
they are moving forward in the
development stages of house of the
dragon
entertainment weekly announced they have
started casting for the show
there wasn't much else said other than
that but that's good enough for me
hbo has already given the green light on
the first season so we don't even have
to worry about whether the first episode
is good enough to air or not
if you remember game of thrones almost
never became a show because of how bad
its first episode was but hbo gave them
another chance to get it right
and they obviously did which led to them
ordering an entire first season
we won't have to worry about that this
time because hbo already ordered 10
episodes for their first season
but anyways now i want to go over some
of the alleged leaks for house of the
dragon
now i don't know who or where these
leaks came from
but someone sent them over to sir hun's
reviews i did notice he has been making
several videos on these leaks
now if you were to ask me if these are
real or not i would have to say no
they are not legit but i want to go over
them anyway because
that's what i have always done like i
said at the beginning of the video
i will inform you on any information
that's out there
this certainly would not be the first
time i have covered some leaks that went
nowhere
so it says the very first episode of
house of the dragon
is said to begin with a shot over
dragonstone we will be able to see
six dragons flying in the distance then
we will hear the sound of a horn
and the scene will transition into
another scene of a dragon rider landing
his dragon on top of the red key
the dragon rider will be none other than
prince daemon targaryen
he is said to be the most experienced
warrior of his time
now besides having his very own dragon
he also has his own valerian steel sword
known as dark sister
after daemon lands his dragon at the red
keep we will see him walking through the
great hall where the iron throne is
located
this is when we will meet the greens the
greens
originally known as the queen's party
were the faction house targaryen
and their loyalists who supported the
ascent of aegon the second as king of
the seven kingdoms
during the dance of the dragons and the
years that followed
after the introductions it is said that
aegon ii makes a joke about
damon saying he looks old and broke then
damon cracks a joke back at him
causing king viserys to step in and make
them stop
now for those of you that don't know
king viserys the first
was also a dragon rider when he was
younger he actually rode
aegon the conqueror's dragon ballarion
the black dread
until the dragon died of old age viserys
never bonded with another dragon after
that
now as this scene continues we will meet
king viserys's wife
alicent hightower she is the daughter of
otto hightower who just so happens to be
the hand of the king
so after we hear aegon ii and daemon
make some jokes
this is when alicent walks into the
throne room we will see her smirk at
daemon
the next scene is said to be in the
north at winterfell
it should look very similar to what we
saw in the first season of game of
thrones
during this scene there will be a feast
held inside winterfell's great hall
the feast is being held in honor of the
new warden of the north kregan stark
the scene ends with cregan stark and his
uncle bernard
speaking alone together in a room
bernard will tell cregan that he thinks
he's not ready to be warden of the north
he says the north is larger than all the
other kingdoms combined
and this responsibility should be left
for a man not a boy
this scene ends when cregan stark leaves
winterfell to gather up all his banners
to go to war against his uncle bernard
in the very next scene we go back to
dragonstone
in raynera targaryen's first scene we
will see her flying on the back of a
dragon
she's also flying with laina who is
riding her own dragon veigar
now lena is the second wife of daemon
targaryen
during this scene rhaenyra and lena will
be seen flying on their dragons circling
dragonstone for several minutes
this will show us just how experienced
they are at flying dragons
for them it's like riding a bike only in
the sky
but they will eventually land on the
beach of dragonstone where they will
have a conversation
they talk about king viserys and queen
alicent having an anniversary that's
coming up very soon
rhaenyra says she has been invited but
she doesn't seem excited
about the news i guess she doesn't want
to go but laina advises against it
since rhaenyra was invited her not
attending could be seen as a slight
against her father the king
and the queen the scene ends with
rhaenyra leaving dragonstone on her
dragon
as she heads for king's landing leida
had asked her to go watch after her
uncle daemon targaryen because he will
most likely get in some trouble while in
the capital
the final scene of this episode shows a
hooded figure walking through the
streets of what appears to be king's
landing
this mysterious figure is shown standing
in front of a red door
as the door swings open we see a drunken
half-naked daemon targaryen standing in
the room
daemon then begins to remove the hood
and robe off the mysterious character
and this is when it is revealed to be
rhaenyra the episode ends as they are
making love
sounds really awesome they should name
the show a game of incestuous
relationships
well those are all the leaks i have so
far as i said before
i'm not sure if they are legit or not
but hey who knows
now if you are wondering what we could
see in house of the dragon let me know
down below because i can start making
videos on each chapter from the fire and
blood book
i could make at least one of those
videos each week
and of course i will continue making
videos on the chapters in a song of ice
and fire as well
i may do it either way since house of
the dragon is still moving forward with
their developments
anyways i hope you all like the update
video i have already started working on
another chapter video so you will hear
from me again very soon
as always thank you for watching the
video and thank you to everyone who went
over and signed up for my patreon i
really appreciate
that it helps out a lot have a great day
everyone
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you